CARTER MORGAN: Welcome to "Cloud
Security Basics," a new series
where we explain the
ins and outs of securing
your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around,
because in this episode,
you'll learn about the first
of three distinct areas
of cloud security risk--
access.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD ACTOR: Hello,
cloud detective.
You showed that you understand
cloud's shared security model,
but can you solve this?
What can you do to
stop the wrong people
from accessing your resources?
For example, I could use
a man-in-the-middle attack
to intrude on an
existing connection,
intercepting and modifying all
network traffic between two
devices.
If I intercepted
an admin's traffic,
I'd even be able to
act on your system
with all the privileges
of your admin.
What can you do to stop that?
For your sake, I hope
you know the answer.
CARTER MORGAN: OK,
here's what we know.
A man-in-the-middle attack
involves an attacker getting
access to credentials
they shouldn't have.
We could solve this,
but there's actually
a broader problem here--
access.
Access represents ensuring that
only the right identities have
access to the right
resources for your system.
For example, you might
not want developers
to be able to delete
resources on your system,
so you have to enact a
policy, or access control,
to prevent that from happening
by accident or ill will.
Or you might want to prevent
malicious access exploits
like phishing, where an
attacker tricks individuals
into giving out
their credentials,
or denial of service attacks,
where an attacker works
to overwhelm a web
service to keep it
from functioning properly.
Luckily, Google Cloud provides
a lot of tools and services
to protect its users.
Some of those protections
include encrypted traffic
and load balancers to combat
man-in-the-middle and DDoS
exploits, universal two-factor
authentication to minimize
phishing, Cloud Identity-Aware
Proxy to make sure that only
the right people get
access to applications,
endpoint management to make
sure that users are using secure
devices to access company
resources, and more.
Let's see how they work.
So how do these tools
keep the wrong people
from accessing your system?
I know that to combat
man-in-the-middle and DDoS
exploits, Google Cloud
encrypts all internet access
at the network level by
default, eliminating the concern
of a passive adversary listening
for sensitive information.
Let me show you how.
Since TLS requires that
servers prove their identity,
active man-in-the-middle attacks
are also much more difficult.
And Google Cloud's front end
and load balancers support TLS
termination while providing an
entry point to Google's massive
serving resources, making a
successful DDoS attack quite
challenging.
Here's how it works.
Load balancers
report information
about incoming traffic to
a central DDoS service.
If it detects that a
DDoS attack is occurring,
it can configure the load
balancers to drop or throttle
the traffic.
Google's central
identity service,
which users see as
the Google login page,
asks for a user
name and password
and assesses risk factors
such as whether users
have logged in from the same
device or location in the past.
The service issues
credentials, such as cookies
and OAuth tokens, to
further protect users.
Oh, and second factors,
such as one-time passwords
or phishing-resistant
security keys,
can also be used by users
when signing in to help
prevent phishing.
In fact, in order to make
phishing less effective,
Google pioneered the
U2F Titan Security Key,
a hardware second factor
that can be associated
with an account so that
login is only possible when
the second factor is present--
the idea being if
you pair something
you know, like a password,
with something you have,
like a security key, phishing
becomes very difficult.
And it's easy to set up, too.
Once you set these
keys up and change
the two-step authentication
to only use security keys
in the Google Admin
UI, then the next time
a developer logs on, after
they enter their password,
they'll be asked to
touch their security key.
Hmm.
How else can we limit
unauthorized access?
What about Cloud
Identity-Aware Proxy, or IAP?
IAP makes it easy for you to put
up an application on the cloud
and configure a
central policy users
have to authenticate against.
Best of all, since IAP is
enforced at the network layer,
Cloud IAP requires little to
no application code changes.
So if you had a legacy
application that
was hosted on-premise
behind a firewall,
and wanted to migrate it to a
public endpoint on the cloud,
you could drop Cloud
IAP in front of it
to require authentication and
authorization against a Google
Group or G Suite domain
with little to no changes
to the application at all.
But that still
leaves the case of,
what if the laptop of an admin
is compromised by malware?
Hmm.
That's where endpoints
management comes in.
If your platform can be
accessed from your employee's
own personal phone
or tablet, you
can use G Suite
Endpoint Management
to keep your company data
safe while letting employees
use their favorite
personal device.
And with endpoints, it
becomes easy to do things
like set up policies.
Like, on Android
devices, work apps
will be separated
from personal apps,
or since Chrome OS is designed
for security from the ground up
and doesn't allow the
installation of software,
only use admin access if the
admin is using a Chromebook.
I figured it out!
I've got the answer!
BRAD ACTOR: Hello, detective.
I see you've been busy.
You've answered my
question-- what can you
do to stop the wrong people
from accessing your data?
You noticed that Google Cloud
could help secure access
and authentication.
Google Cloud provides help
through Identity-Aware Proxy,
endpoint verification,
universal two-factor, and more.
All of these features
are building up
context associated
with the access
to make sure it
follows the rules.
The access should come
from a Chromebook,
the user should have proper
credentials to log in,
they should have the
required access levels,
and they need to have a
hardware second factor in order
to get to the particular API.
These individual protections
layer on top of each other
to help keep your cloud
safer and more secure.
Very good, very good.
You've answered
today's question,
but be ready,
because next time I
want to see what you can
do to keep your data safe.
CARTER MORGAN: So
there you have it--
another episode of
"Cloud Security Basics."
Next episode will focus on the
second of three distinct areas
of cloud security risk--
data.
In the meantime, if you
want to take a deeper
dive into securing
access in the cloud,
then check out the article
linked in the description
below, and stay tuned for the
rest of the Cloud Security
Basics series because
when it comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]